hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher a challenge with the subject of
mathematics specifically is that one of
the most amazing things about
mathematics I think is that it is
timeless you know once you prove
something is true in mathematics it's
true forever and I love that we can
study ancient theorems and we don't have
to update them or revise them because
people have discovered new evidence they
are eternal and still true whether we
discovered them centuries ago or last
year and I think that's brilliant but at
the same time it presents a challenge
for us attention because while the
subject is timeless the way the subject
is applied in the real world is not and
there's a real temptation to you know
hold to these ways of the past because
mathematics is still true it's
arithmetic is still true calculus is
still true but to not move with the
future and to say you know what as a
profession and as a discipline we still
have to stay up-to-date we want to
maintain that tension between
prizing these things that are eternally
true but also making sure we connect to
students in the real world the world
they live in now and the ways that
mathematics applies in ways that didn't
happen in decades and centuries past
I think holding that tension is
difficult to do but it's really
important if we want our students to
understand this timeless beauty of the
subject but also see it in connection to
their actual lives
[Music]